hacking isn't Criminal hacking is a
technique hacking is uh a mindset it's a
tool set hacking is a way of thinking
the tools of hackers and the techniques
of hackers can be employed to commit
crimes but hacking is always about like
breaking things to make them better
we're making the world a better place
we're all fighting for the same thing we
all want Universal human rights we want
the internet to flourish as this
beautiful platform where everyone has
equal access so that we can all
communicate without persecution from
some big brother or some oppressive
government it's beautiful the world has
never known an an infrastructure a land
that allows everyone to be equal when I
go online you're your black text on a
white screen we're all equal and judged
by what we say and think not our
financial status or our religious
background or our skin color it's
beautiful